- If you think you can
have a balanced life
as an entrepreneur,
that's just all bullshit.
What I've learned about business
over all these years and all these deals,
it's never as good as it sounds,
but it's never as bad as it looks either.
♫ This land is your land
♫ This land is my--
I screwed it up, let's start again.
(audience laughing)
- Hello believe nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn from
Shark Tank investor, Kevin O'Leary,
and my take on his Top
10 Rules For Success,
Volume Two.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(cosmic whoosh)
(dramatic music)
- I was working once
at an ice-cream parlor
when I was about 15 years old,
my first real job.
And on the second day,
I was asked to scrape the gum off
between the Mexican tiles on the floor,
and I said to the woman
who owned the store,
it was called Magoo's Ice-Cream Parlor,
you didn't hire me to scrape gum,
you hired me to scoop ice-cream.
And this girl in the
shoe store across the way
that's looking at me,
I don't want her to see
me scraping the gum.
And she said, "What are you talking about?
"I own this store,
"I'll do anything I want with you.
"Get down on your knees
and scrape that gum."
And I said, "I'm not doing it."
She said, "You're fired."
Last job I ever had.
(audience chuckles)
I owe that woman everything.
I don't like to work for people.
Many of you in here I hope inherit that.
There's nothing wrong with it.
If you want to control your own destiny,
you work for yourself.
That's how it works.
I'm trying to inspire those of you
who are on the tipping point.
Take the chance, you're young.
Go for it.
There's nothing better than being able
to wake up in the morning,
10 years or 20 years from now,
and do whatever you like.
It's about freedom.
That's what matters.
I'm not saying being an employee's bad,
but believe me, being an
entrepreneur is better.
I'm a little biased.
(audience laughing)`
Unfortunately, one of the great benefits
of technology's productivity.
One of the big down sides,
it's incredibly distracting.
People check their Twitter account
or they'll answer a Facebook message,
or they'll do something
that has nothing to do
with making money.
And the reason you go
to work in the morning
is to make money.
That's what you're there for.
All the other wonderful things
you can do with your time
are based on your ability to
create an income for yourself
and your family.
So why spend any time doing all that crap,
which is distracting?
And so that's the number one thing
I find in my companies is
when you see someone failing
and you look at how
they manage their time,
you'll see right there what's going on.
They're not focused on what matters.
- Last time we were here
we talked about your
meeting with Steve Jobs,
and I read a lot about Steve
Jobs since he passed away,
and people talk about he was
so unbelievably difficult
and tough in a way.
- Yes he was.
- Would you characterize
him that way, yeah?
- He was a prick.
- Yeah?
(audience laughing)
But do you have to be that way
to accomplish what he's done?
- You know, I respect him
for the tremendous success
and the vision he had.
I was proud to work for him,
because that's what I was doing,
supplying him educational software.
I always thought in person
he could've been a nicer guy,
but would that have
changed the outcome?
Maybe.
He was a genius,
and I remember him saying,
I asked him about,
"Well, maybe we should do
"some market research on this
"before we spend two million dollars,"
on a particular product we're
doing for Reader Rabbit.
And he said, "We don't do market research.
"We tell them what they want."
and I thought wow,
not only is that arrogant,
but it's brilliant.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- And it worked.
- Right.
- And so again I said,
"Okay big guy, let's do it."
And it was very successful.
That whatever you do,
somebody can do it better.
You have to bring your
A-game in every single day.
There's nothing unique
about any one individual.
What's unique is their passion,
their ability to execute,
to meet targets and exceed them.
The minute you lose that ability,
in capitalism, you're gone.
It's a fair trade.
The engine that makes you rich
can take it all away from you.
There are no guarantees.
I think that's incredibly important.
- What's a deal that you missed
that one of your fellow
sharks was able to secure
that you look back on and say,
"Wow, I didn't know that one
was going to work out that well,
"but it's proven to be a big success."?
- And there is one,
and I remember the moment.
It was that deal called Sponge Daddy.
It was a yellow sponge
with a smile in its face.
And I thought, "What a
piece of crap this is.
The guy wanted $500,000
for, like, 50% of it.
And Laurie was beside me,
you know, the queen of
crap, as I like to say.
She'd get the joke if she was here.
And she started bidding on it,
and I looked over at her and I said,
"Are you out of your mind?
"This thing is a sponge.
"It's a sponge."
She said, "Leave me alone."
I said, "No, Laurie, I
forbid you to do this.
"I can't watch you kill money like this.
"This is a shame.
"You're going to teach
America how to waste cash."
She said, "Shut up, I'm doing the deal."
And she did.
Sponge Daddy did $50
million in sales last year.
It's a little piece of crap.
I mean, that taught me a--
and I have a lot of respect for her now.
That shows you the power
of the Shark Tank platform.
Simple product, simple message.
There's actually a great
corporate lesson to be learned
in watching Shark Tank.
And I urge anybody that's
listening to this now
to think about this for their own career.
If you go back and look
at six years of data,
of all the deals that got funded,
regardless to what the product was.
This does not detail the
outcome of the company,
just the ones that go
a check from a shark.
What are the common traits or threads?
It turns out there's three.
In 100% of the cases,
the entrepreneur was able
to articulate the idea
in 90 seconds or less.
Here's a sponge.
Under cold water it's hard,
scrapes eggs off plates,
under warm water you can polish silver.
I get it, right?
Very simple.
Number two: it's usually a team
are able to articulate
why they're right team
to execute the business plan.
They have a plan.
They tell you what it
is and they tell you why
they're the accredited managers for it.
That's interesting.
You find it in every case with a success.
And here's the one that really matters.
In 100% of the cases,
the entrepreneurs knew
their numbers inside out.
If you would ask them
about break even analysis,
margin analysis, market
share growth, competition,
in every answer they
had it, they nailed it.
It turns out in corporate America today,
and I teach this now,
you know, I taught at Norte Dame, at MIT,
the graduating cohorts,
I explained this to them.
When you're leading, when
you want to be a leader,
you have to articulate your
idea in 90 seconds or less.
You have to explain why you're
the right person to lead,
and above all you have
to know your numbers.
You can see it happen on Shark Tank.
It works in the real world too.
And frankly Shark Tank is the real world
because it's real capital.
So I use that and I teach it,
and I think everybody
should think about that.
Explaining your vision
clearly, succinctly,
in a short period of time ends
up being really important.
If you think you can have a
balanced life as an entrepreneur
that's just all bullshit.
There's some other guy
who wants your customer
that's working 25 hours a day.
- Right.
- That's what I found,
and so I don't even talk
about that any more,
saying look, it's a great--
You have to decide.
It's a path.
You either are going to
control your own destiny,
or you're going to be an employee.
They're both noble.
One gives you time to be with your family,
one gives you a more balanced life,
and the other one is balls to the wall,
and the reason you do it is
to eventually have personal freedom
because you've been successful.
And I think most of
the people in this room
fall into that second category,
balls to the walls,
and they're going to
make it or they're not,
and that's why I come here,
'cause I was a kindred spirit.
I like to see entrepreneurs
that are willing to risk it all,
but have to realize there is no balance.
The reason why you do and
pursue an entrepreneurial career
is to provide financial freedom one day
for yourself and your family.
The sacrifice is there's no balance
during the period that
you're growing your business.
If you're successful,
the reward is financial freedom,
which is the essence.
I tell the entrepreneurs,
"Don't do it for the greed of money.
"Do it for financial freedom.
"Do it for freedom.
"Make yourself free one day
"so you can do whatever
you wish with your time."
And the only way you can
do that in our society
is you have to be wealthy to do that.
And so the rewards of a
great entrepreneur are
they achieve that wealth and they're free
to do whatever they wish,
which may be more entrepreneurship.
You don't know.
If you're passionate
and you're successful,
you will wake up one day rich.
You won't really be going for the cash,
it'll just happen to you.
Everybody I talk to that's had success
doesn't remember the day
they became a millionaire.
No idea.
Not important to them.
They remember winning.
They remember building a business
and being successful.
Again, the pursuit of freedom
manifests itself in passion.
That's really what it's about.
- And to my exposure,
most of the business people I've met,
the successful ones, the CEOs or whatever,
they are at their core optimistic.
Can you be a pessimist and
be a successful entrepreneur?
You have to be optimistic?
- I think you have to view the world
in a way that assumes success,
otherwise you'll never have the energy.
Maybe not a pessimist,
but a skeptic is a good thing to be,
because what I've learned about business
over all these years and all these deals,
it's never as good as it sounds
but it's never as bad as it looks either.
Every day, I've got 32
portfolio companies now,
something wildly bad is
happening to one of them,
and the cellphone rings
at six in the morning,
and something fantastically great
is happening to another one.
And it seems to me,
the random serendipitous nature of it all
is really intriguing to me,
because if I could only
show the pessimistic
or very depressed entrepreneur that
is calling me saying, "Oh my goodness,
"we just lost Walmart," or whatever it is,
it's the nightmare of their day,
versus, "We just got Walmart,"
on the other business.
Well I'm trying to get
everybody in the same universe
to realize it's never as bad as it sounds,
but never as good either.
You have to get up in the
morning and go back to work.
Great entrepreneurs are able to delegate.
The successful women CEOs
are remarkably good at this.
Remarkably good at it.
And the way it works is,
Sarah, I'll give you an example
of the way Sarah works.
She hires somebody,
she sets a goal for 90 days,
and gets out of their way.
Gets completely out of their way.
Lets them achieve it.
It they achieve it she moves
them up the organization.
If they don't, they get three
tries until they're out.
If you can't achieve
your goals in business,
that's what happens.
But her whole thing is
let them do the work themselves,
let them figure it out.
I don't want to use my time for it,
that's what I hired them for.
What do you want to play?
(plucks guitar)
See, if I think--
- Kevin O'Leary, you know what I want
you to play for me?
- (strums guitar)
- I want you to sing
This Land Is Your Land.
- Ooh.
(audience laughing)
- The classic, pro-labor,
political subversive song.
We got to bring the lyrics--
- I got to tell ya,
'cause I got to have the lyrics,
'cause I'd never sing this thing.
- (laughs) I know, that sounds good.
- This is absolutely
against everything I am.
- [Host] I know (laughs).
(audience laughing)
(strumming guitar)
- Remember this tune?
Starts with a G.
Ready?
We're going to go.
♫ This land is your land
♫ This land is my--
I screwed it up, let's start again.
(audience laughing)
That's how much I hate
this tune.
- It sounds good.
That's all it is, right?
♫ This land is your land
♫ This land is my land
♫ From California
♫ To the New York island
♫ Cape (unclear)
- Ooh, I hate this tune.
- (laughs)
- All right.
♫ This land is your land
- Okay, go, go.
- Let's try it again.
I want you to sing with me.
- Dude, are you crazy?
- You're not
getting away with this.
- All right.
(audience laughing)
- All right,
here we go.
♫ This land is your land
♫ This land is my land
♫ From California
♫ To the New York islands
♫ Blah blah-blah blah blah blah
♫ To the Gulf Stream waters
- Here we go.
- Everybody!
♫ This land was made for you and me
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
If you want to get your pick
of who I should profile next
in the Top Tens,
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Amy Schmittauer.
Amy, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word,
and doing that awesome
podcast on your channel,
and you Tweeting it out.
I appreciate all the support,
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(cosmic whoosh)
- Great entrepreneurs have a
tremendous amount of knowledge
of what they're selling.
They know a lot about everything,
but they better know a lot
about what they're selling.
You never want to be
caught explaining yourself
and not knowing your product.
That's because you're so passionate
you're spending all your time doing it.
That's exactly what matters.
I actually think what
motivates entrepreneurs
is fear of failure,
and this certainly happened to me.
You start a deal, it's not working,
you work harder to make it work,
you pivot, you figure out
what you're doing wrong.
Fear of failure is the
ultimate motivation,
and I think many--
Every entrepreneur has failures.
Your job is to go out into the world
and understand who you serve.
It is not your responsibility
to solve all the societies' problems.
You pay taxes to a government to do that.
Your job
is to go to war every day and win.
To win market share.
To salt the earth your
competitors walk on.
To steal their customers,
and to take their profits and win.
That's your job.
And to make profits for your shareholders
so they give you more
capital to create more jobs,
to be more successful, to pay more taxes,
to provide the standard of living
that we have in America today.
Your job is not to solve
everybody's problem.
It's to solve your customer's problems,
your shareholders problems,
your employees problems.
I'm very distressed when people tell me
a business should give a third
of it's profits to charity.
That's outrageous.
It should give all of
it to its shareholders
who then give to charity.
Think of all the great
things that are done today
by the Bill Gates of the world,
the Warren Buffets of the world.
The only reason they can do that
is they make money for their shareholders.
Don't get lost in this debate.
Stay focused and true to the mission.
Business is war.
You have to win.
And you take the spoils which are profits,
and you help your fellow man.
But first you make money.